Olivia Wolke hat gefragt,
was eigentlich mit unserem Hüftgold
passiert, wenn wir abnehmen?
*Titelmusik*
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
Der Begriff "Fett verbrennen"
kommt nicht von ungefähr.
Für Chemiker ist eine Verbrennung
eine Reaktion eines brennbaren
Stoffes mit Sauerstoff.
Genauer gesagt eine Redoxreaktion,
unter der Abgabe von Wärme,
oft auch Licht.
Bei der Verbrennung
von Kohlenwasserstoffen z.B.
werden bei den hohen Temperaturen
die Kohlenstoffatome
und die Wasserstoffatome
auseinandergerissen
und mit Sauerstoffatomen
wieder zusammengeschmissen.
Am Ende bleiben
von den Kohlenwasserstoffen
nur noch Kohlendioxid
und Wasser übrig.
Zumindest bei einer
vollständigen Verbrennung.
In der Praxis haben wir meistens
eine unvollständige Verbrennung.
So entsteht z.B. auch
das giftige Kohlenmonoxid.
Okay, aber was hat das jetzt
mit der Fettverbrennung
in unserem Körper zu tun?
Unser Körper besteht z.T.
aus den unbeliebten
aber überlebenswichtigen Fettzellen.
Deren Hauptaufgabe ist es,
Energie zu speichern,
wenn mal keine Energie,
z.B. durch Essen, vorhanden ist.
Fettzellen sind so ähnlich
aufgebaut wie normale Zellen.
Nur bestehen sie zu 90 % aus Fett.
Sie haben einen Fettspeicher,
bestehend aus Triglycerin.
Die sehen so aus:
Sie bestehen
aus einem Glycerolbindestück,
das aussieht wie ein "E"
und da hängen längere
Kohlenwasserstoffketten dran.
Das sind die Fettsäuren.
Fett hat viel Energie,
eine deutlich höhere Energiedichte
als Kohlenhydrate oder Proteine.
Diese Energie sitzt in den Bindungen
zwischen den Kohlenstoffatomen
und kann freigesetzt werden,
wenn die Bindungen gebrochen werden.
Wenn wir länger nicht zu essen
bekommen, oder Sport machen,
d.h., wenn der Körper Energie
braucht, werden die Triglyceride
in kleinere Teile zersetzt.
Es entstehen zunächst
Glycerol und Fettsäuren.
Diese kleineren Teile können jetzt
aus den Fettzellen ausbrechen
und in die Blutbahn gelangen.
Dadurch schrumpfen die Fettzellen.
D.h., man kann Fett verbrennen -
Fettzellen aber nicht.
Die werden nur kleiner oder größer,
je nachdem ob man zu- oder abnimmt.
Jedenfalls, Glycerol und Fettsäuren
gehen in die Muskeln und die Leber.
Dort werden die Moleküle
noch weiter zerteilt,
bis am Ende noch
CO2 und Wasser übrig bleiben.
Also genau wie bei einer
klassischen Verbrennung.
CO2 atmen wir aus,
Wasser scheiden wir aus.
Nur im Gegensatz
zu einer klassischen Verbrennung
verlaufen die Reaktionen nicht durch
Hitze sondern mithilfe von Enzymen.
Außerdem entsteht bei der Fett-
verbrennung ein Molekül namens ATP.
Adenosin-Tri-Phosphat.
Das ATP ist ein Energieträger,
ein Kraftstoff sozusagen, für alles,
das uns Energie kostet.
Sei es Sport oder auch nur so Sachen
wie Verdauung oder Herzschlag.
Erinnert ihr euch noch an eine
unserer 1. Folgen mit dem Kaffee?
Nee, grad nicht, danke.
Da ging's darum, was Koffein
in unserem Gehirn macht
und da war von Adenosin die Rede.
Wenn wir viel Adenosin haben,
werden wir müde.
Wisst ihr, woher das kommt?
Vom ATP.
Bei allem, was uns Energie kostet,
verbrauchen wir
Adenosin-Triphosphat - ATP.
Und was am Ende davon übrig bleibt,
ist nur das A - Adenosin.
Voll cool, oder?
Also noch mal:
Fett lagert in unseren Fettzellen.
Wenn wir Sport machen oder abnehmen,
wird das Fett
in kleinere Teile zerbrochen
und die werden dann im Stoffwechsel
zu CO2, Wasser und ATP umgewandelt.
Wenn man so drüber nachdenkt,
ist es ziemlich abgefahren,
was unser Körper so alles macht
und wie er es schafft,
Moleküle zu zerbrechen.
Beim Fett verbrennen
macht unser Körper
eigentlich schon die meiste Arbeit.
Das wir ihm damit ein bisschen Sport
unter die Arme greifen,
ist ja wohl das mindeste, oder?
Schön schlau!
Vielen Dank, Olivia,
für deine Frage.
Wenn ihr noch Fragen habt,
schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Und wenn ihr
nach diesem Körpereinsatz
das nicht abonniert,
dann habt ihr kein Herz.
- Kamera läuft.
- Es entstehen zunächst Glycerol
und Fettsäuren. - Falsch rum.
Außerdem... - Ja, so ist gut.
Außerdem entsteht bei der... (lacht)
Irgendwie bin ich zu kurz,
sieht das irgendwie aus? War's gut?
Ich hab so das Gefühl, ich mach
überhaupt gar keine Bewegung.
- Nee, nee. - Ich hab zu kurze Arme.